und hat uns empfangen in seinem kleinen
haus in schweden wo er mit seiner
familie lebt
meine kollegin sibylle marti eine
bekennende klausel mahnen hat ihn
besucht
ein interview mit karl uwe knaus gott
ist ein seltsames gefühl ich treffe
einen menschen in denen ich mich während
monaten richtiggehend hinein gelesen
habe
heute lebt er hier in einem kleinen
südschwedischen dorf es ist ruhig die
einwohner interessieren sich nicht für
ihn und genau das hat er wohl besucht
hierher hat er sich mit seiner frau und
vier kindern zurückgezogen will sein
familienleben schützen eben jenes das er
minutiös vor uns ausgebreitet hat
[Musik]
was ist das für ein mensch ein
größenwahnsinniger egomane und ich
einfach opfer eines tourismus oder ist
er dieser sensible genaue lebens
erkunder als den ich ihnen seinen
büchern glaubte ganz nah kennenzulernen
es ist eigenartig dieses gefühl von
intimität dass sie woods ihren das macht
auch etwas angst
hat mir erst
wenn ich daran denke dann macht es angst
oder dann aber ich tue es nicht
es ist als ob es nicht existierte wenn
ich sie treffe denke ich nicht dass sie
alles wissen dass er es gelesen haben
wenn ich daran denken würde würde ich
verrückt
wenn millionen menschen glauben ein zu
kennen das kann man wohl nur verdrängen
klaus gott wird etwas abgekämpft müde
als wäre sein werk größer geworden als
er es tragen kann
er erzählt mir von seinem leidensweg von
den langen jahren gefangen im schreib
versagen vom riesigen frust bis zu
seinem befreiungsschlag
[Musik]
dann schrieb ich eine episode aus meiner
kindheit
über einen sehr bescheidenen moment den
ich nie jemandem erzählt hast und ich
schickte ihn meinem lektor bei nantes
manische brächte er war ein bisschen
besorgt
und in diesem enthüllen eines
geheimnisses nicht von einer figur
sondern von mir selbst fühlte ich einen
enormen kick
ich realisierte dass steckt so viel
energie zählen und es ist sehr einfach
ich kann es einfach machen wenn ich
keine angst habe vor den konsequenzen
kann ich es einfach machen
von da an war das ventil offen alles kam
auf papier aus gold publizierte sein
leben seine geheimnisse der sturm tobte
los sein umfeld bebte alle wollten die
bücher genau so manni bekennen die
geschichte
es war schrecklich für alle um mich
herum es war so intensiv und ich war der
einzige der damit nichts zu tun hatte
die zeitungen haben alles mögliche
gemacht mich haben sie in ruhe gelassen
ich war mitten im sturm am schreiten
[Musik]
ich erinnere mich an einen moment in
oslo als ich denke großen norwegischen
literatur preis gewarnt für das erste
buch
zur nacht
einfach gelacht
so ein rummel hat es in norwegen noch
nie gegeben wegen einem buch
ich muss zugeben das war ein moment ist
das ist alles wovon du kannst als autor
da nämlich alle kontroversen und
probleme und familie hin das war einfach
wunderbar
sind sie glücklich heute
[Musik]
das ist noch von glück ist nicht für
mich
[Musik]
das ist ein ur konflikt in mir
ich habe wenig selbstvertrauen
ich denke nichts was ich habe ist
wertvoll und wenn jemand mit mir
befreundet sein will dann bin ich
misstrauisch wieso ich
langweilig
ich rede nicht aber
so ist es nicht wenn ich schreibe
ich habe einen enormen andrang jemand zu
sein allen zu zeigen schaut her
das ist eher kindlich aber ich tue es
für mich ich versuche mich selbst
präsent zu machen
damit er sich nicht selbst entschwindet
schreibt er jeden tag und erkämpft
es ist sehr schwer zu schreiben jetzt
mach ich mir bewusst bin dass die leute
erwartungen haben wollen dies oder jenes
und ich denke es muss richtig gut sein
weil dieses buch sein erfolg war das
muss besser sein wenn du so denkst dann
bist du tot nun muss ich einen weg da
raus finden
ziemlich genau so habe ich mit klaus
gott vorgestellt traurig
etwas manisch und
warmherzig einer der aus großer not im
schreiben den ort gefunden hat oder
existiert zum glück für uns leser
[Musik]